well a whole lot of trash and violence
with no Solutions viewers in the East
Valley reached out to us concerned about
two of their neighbors but police say
the people who are living in some of
these homes are making it a challenge to
really do anything about it 8 news now
reporter Ryan Matthey explains why
it's a homeowner's worst nightmare
neighbors side by side that bring trash
violence and other disruptions to daily
life but according to law enforcement
correcting their actions is not so easy
it's in this neighborhood off Charleston
and lamb both homes collecting garbage
and broken down cars this one doesn't
even have a garage door
neighbors are unsure who lives there or
who's just spending the night in the
driveway but when I went door to door
most neighbors did not want to talk on
camera you've got the camera
specifically to monitor that yeah but
Sheridan shumate did it's like carts
broken up carts things like that
whatever just mutilated metal objects
laying out in the street or rolled out
into the street he adds fights in the
street have become a weekly occurrence
too with fireworks shot off from outside
these homes late at night landing on his
home I'm not anyone to tell someone what
to do on their property it's that's a
hard line for me you know
um but you are they are definitely
impacting everyone around them a Metro
Police representative confirming the
owners are allowing these quote-unquote
guests onto their property and as such
is not considered
yeah and when I spoke to one person who
says they live here he could not tell me
how many people reside at this house but
he adds drug use and mental health
concerns are common amongst those
residing there I've been here a year and
a half and nothing's changed
now Ryan did contact the owners of the
property he says those calls were never
returned but a Clark County
representative did confirm to him that
both properties have open cases against
them for things like violations
regarding outside storage waste
accumulation and prohibited car repair